when you're working yes dear okay since
this here right it's just a bit awkward
to write often you will find as people
keep working on the question and even
like specimen solutions in that kind of
thing they keep on referring to the
population there's ten thousand minus
eight thousand a to the minus KT it just
makes the for intiation a bit simpler
you just don't have this gorgeous
numbers floating around and then when
you need to evaluate something you
reintroduce it okay so I'm gonna use
with them right up this list here okay
this is my line to differentiate from
okay because I can when I need the value
of K I can put in because I already know
what it is it's just a little work with
okay so we're gonna differentiate this
what happens when I visit to the ten
thousand disappears their problem what
happens to the rest of it well you're
gonna get the derivative of the inside
function the inside function being minus
KT so there's my dreary on the inside
then you differentiate the outside it's
an exponential so what happens to it
nothing happens to it gets an
exponential right so you go times eight
thousand e to the KT right that should
be plus it's at a cape a double negative
is canceled right okay now have a look
at this for a second this is um this is
a bit of a problem right because in
exponential growth indicate situations
what we used to see is this you
differentiate right and if it's a growth
situation remember this like the first
part of the question pie a it's always
really obvious you expect to get back
the population where the constant hey
you're from the constant of
proportionality right but this this this
is not just I should don't rush it right
okay this is not just KP it's not is it
what's missing from here that the shift
is missing the 10,000 is missing of
course it's missing because it's a
constant right but then how do i account
for it here okay now I did this on
double negative here right I'm actually
going to put it back there because we'll
make things a bit easier for me to see I
put a minus back here and this is
actually - Matt okay so I literally just
unchain without no simplifying okay can
you see that this part in here is not
pain it's not just KP but it's close to
pay right
I'll close to P is it it's only off by a
question right this is this is not P
it's 10,000 less than P isn't it if I
take 10,000 away from this that I'll
take it away there you go that's what
I've got inside the brackets there right
it's 10,000 less than pitch so therefore
I can say this it's P minus 10,000 is n
okay all I've done is I've looked at
this and said whoops this is 10,000 too
big okay so therefore I'll take 10,000
away and off I go that's what I've got
inside the brackets okay I'll just apply
one more thing and then you tell me what
this means
this is the proportionality thing that
we were sort of sort of expecting but
it's different how is it different on
what does that mean we constantly ask
you the question what did these
equations mean when we're in a physical
situation like this right if these are
population it's 10,000 minus pain 10,000
minus pain of what for instance and a
point like this right 10,000 minus pay
would be 8,000 wouldn't it right at a
point like this 10,000 minus P would be
4,000 and as I go through 10,000 minus P
is this vertical distance here that's a
really messy 10,000 you get the idea
okay that dis is there always that's
10,000 minus peach from Bowser minus P
and so on okay so what we've determined
is that how the population is changing
is not proportional to the population
instead it's proportional to this
distance what is this distance it's the
difference between what the population
is and what it could be it's the
difference between the pop of what the
population is and where it's headed
right it's this gap okay so we should
write this down right the rate of change
of the population or the population rate
of change okay it's not proportional to
the population that's why these
constraints they change these quite
dramatically right the population rate
of change is proportional to how'd you
win it
it's a difference isn't it sums and
differences this is a difference the
difference is a team where you're headed
what your constraint is what your
boundary is right and we're sure to the
difference between the population and
the constraint or if you want to use a
chemical word because this space will
often come up as well it's kind of your
equilibrium right it's what your head
seems it's a sort of stable condition
all right that's what you headed towards
once you get toward there the population
is gonna level off there and it's not
gonna change right so that's what we're
headed towards that's what it's
proportional to crucial idea that's why
it's modified it's not just slightly
different it's actually portion to a
different thing that was a right there
there's B let's do C let's finish it
we've done all the hard work now we do
the easy bit 8,000 8,000 where am I
going to put in where does it belong it
belongs right here doesn't it 8,000
equals and then all I have to solve is T
okay here's the mechanical bit let's
just do it and see if we can draw some
conclusions from it okay I'm gonna need
more horizontal space 8000 equals 10,000
minus 8,000
okay let's tidy up a few numbers if I
got 8,000-10,000 right I'm gonna get -
mm over here divide through by a
coefficient see you just get AK one take
logs what are you gonna get okay now
your before I resisted turning this into
a log 2 and evaluating the negative
because I thought well I'm gonna have
another negative floating around anyway
so they cancelled uh but now I've got
two of these guys right and they both
this is this is negative log 4 isn't it
because that's 4 to power minus 1 and
that's negative log 2 so I'm just gonna
do both of those right now you should
keep this practice thick as the t's not
in there and here is what I'm getting 3
log 4 on on 2 now I know you could reach
to your calculator right now I know you
could but I deliberately chose these
numbers because they're nice and simple
come on do we really need calculators
for this log for our log 2 of course
this is change of base rule but in
Reverse you're used to doing it the
other way right so this is really time
equals 3 log base 2 of 4 which is 2
that's 6 6 years now stop for a moment
this is that consistent and what does it
mean are we going let's see okay that's
here right and we might be across to
here my graph miraculously turns out to
be pretty accurate okay now this is
interesting to me this is very
interesting it took me three years to go
from here to here
right and then jump another three years
to go just this distance why was this
show little population change here the
quite a bit here
why because I because I'm approaching
the limit of population right people the
big ones those numbers all around better
slow down I'm less likely to have
children and so on right so it makes
sense of the situation it's a number is
Kirk here there's your answer